what do you think going to happen with
bitcoin i mean
where do you see that going that's in
sort of your area
uh i i see it bringing down civilization
but maybe i'm being involved so no i i
so you know it depends on what angle of
bitcoin and cryptocurrency
but cryptocurrency is the is i see it
one of the
single enabling factors that has allowed
cyber criminals to deploy a massive
amount of ransomware
across our state local agencies it is
the anonymous payments the ability to
pay
anonymously and and i think that is the
cyber threat that the average american
is most concerned about sure because
they feel it at home
all this other stuff about russia and
china right that's
ephemeral yes you're talking about
schools i think something like 1600
schools that were hit last year in
hospitals and government agencies right
i mean we had
baltimore got hit twice atlanta
mecklenburg county north carolina
23 counties in texas uh
louisiana's been hit a couple times it's
just it's it's and this and they just
want money
this is not anything anything
sophisticated this is not
ideological it's like at the end of die
hard when he finds out no
they're not terroristic if there's a
vulnerability yeah
right right it's a little bit like that
okay knock sony tower right
if there's if there's a vulnerability if
there's an exploit
if there is money or information to be
had and there are no meaningful
consequences
the bad guys are going to run wild so
we've got to change that equation i
think looking at
the cryptocurrencies and the in the
exchange wallets we need to look at that
we need to start holding some of these
countries like russia that allow these
cyber criminals to operate
in their sovereign territory with
impunity you know we need to focus on
that
uh but but bringing it back home we've
got to help state locals
improve their defenses and and i i fear
it's only going to get worse
because the the way that tax revenues at
the state and local level have
taken a real hit because of cobin i
think i think when we talk about
infrastructure and investments i think
we've got to have a 21st century
digital infrastructure investment well
tell biden you're
tell biden you're ready to go back to
work hopefully he's watching
you